the supreme court strikes down the trump
administration striking down obama's
daca program the atlanta d.a charges an
officer for murder
after the officer shoots a man who stole
a police taser and fired it at him and
atlanta police officers reportedly walk
walk off the job i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn stop putting your online data
at risk stop that get protected at
expressvpn.com
ben we're gonna get to all the news and
boy is there a lot of news today man
this news cycle is just
insane it's basically the movie twister
except with news we're gonna get to all
of that in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that now is a great time to
keep your property safe and secure and
know what is going on on your property
at all times not only do you want to
know who's arriving at your front door
and dropping off packages and whether
you just
sneezed on those packages you also want
to be able to keep track of your kids
who are now running willy-nilly across
your property which is a thing that my
children have been doing
constantly for months and this is why i
love my ring devices
ring make sure that my property is safe
they are on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer as well
their home security products are
designed to give you peace of mind
around the clock
from video doorbells and security
cameras to smart security lighting and
alarm systems ring has everything you
need to make sure your family and
belongings are safe and secure
anytime anywhere and with the all-new
ring video doorbell 3 you can keep an
even closer eye on things than ever
before we've had some safety issues in
my neighborhood among others and we're
on top of it because of ring we know
exactly what's going on in our
neighborhood
and that makes us feel a lot more secure
get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit when you go to ring.com that
welcome kid includes the ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro
it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today just
go to ring.com
that is ring.com get started building
that
ring of security right now ring.com and
get that welcome kit
including the ring video doorbell 3 and
chime pro with a special offer ring dot
com
slash ben okay so we'll get to
everything that is happening in atlanta
in just a second because
it is chaotic and it is also an
excellent indicator of where america's
major cities are going
and let's just say it's not a good
direction we'll get to that in a second
first the breaking news
as of this hour is the supreme court has
just ruled that president trump does not
have the ability to strike down
the obama administration's deferred
action for childhood arrivals program
now that's not really what the supreme
court said what the supreme court
actually said
is that trump could do it but he did it
wrong so the supreme court has taken up
a line of cases recently that basically
says
orange man bad right in other words if
the orange man did it right
it would be okay what he did but he did
it wrong so it's not okay what he did
and that that is what this case is so
you will recall that barack obama
claimed dozens of times literally dozens
of times that he did not have the
unilateral ability to simply legalize
illegal immigrants in the united states
and then he ignored all of that and he
just said okay you know what
we're not prosecuting anybody who's here
illegally we're just not going to do it
if you are between the ages of 16 and 30
if you came here as a child we are not
going to prosecute you we are not going
to deport you now
maybe that's good policy maybe it's not
but that's something congress has to do
you don't just get to do that as
president of the united states decide
that an entire class of human beings are
no longer prosecutable
because you're the president of the
united states that violates every
statutory rule of interpretation it just
does not work that way
and the obama administration offered no
real justification for this
they didn't offer any sort of legal
memorandum explaining why the law
required this what you're supposed to do
if you're the executive branch because
you execute the laws you don't make them
instead they just declared that they
would start handing out
papers that they would start protecting
you from deportation
and all the rest so the trump
administration comes in and they say
listen we're reversing this
right this is this is illegal jeff
sessions is justice department says this
is no longer legal we are rescinding
this
this is not correct the department of
homeland security rescinds the dapa
memo in june 2017 citing the fact that
it is unconstitutional and that the
federal government
the executive branch does not have the
power to unilaterally declare who they
will and will not prosecute on a
class-wide basis it's one thing to
pardon somebody it's one thing to
commute a sentence it's one thing to use
prosecutorial destruction
discretion it is another thing to
completely invalidate a law just because
you don't like the law
right that's not something that the
executive branch has the power to do
that september in september of 2017 the
attorney general was then jeff sessions
advised the acting secretary of homeland
security elaine duke that daca shared
legal flaws and should be rescinded the
next day duke
acted on that advice and wrote the
so-called duke memo which basically
suggested things unconstitutional and
then a few months later there was
something called the nielsen memo and
the nielsen memo came out that was from
the new department of homeland security
secretary
nielsen bridget nielsen and that more
fully explained the rationale for
rescinding daca
so there's nothing illegal about what
the trump administration did they said
this is an illegal order
it was poorly formulated it was never
legal in the first place obama himself
had said it was never legal in the first
place and so the supreme court has now
held that you're not allowed to rescind
an illegal order unless you go through
all of the hoops of the administrative
procedures act so the administrative
procedures act is basically
an act that creates internal judicial
mechanisms for administrative agencies
so let's say that the epa promulgates a
rule
and you want to sue the epa because you
don't like the epa's rule you have to
sue them in an epa court essentially
well the same thing holds true here is
that the administrative agencies
are tasked with defining their own
regulations and their own rules
and a court is not supposed to interfere
this is called the chevron's doctrine
the court is not supposed to interfere
in the decision-making processes of
administrative agencies unless the
administrative agency
has been arbitrary and capricious is
generally the standard that is used well
the problem is this the obama
administration
did not provide any rationale for why
tackle was constitutional so they were
arbitrary and capricious
but the supreme court didn't find them
arbitrary in capricious so now
they're saying that the trump
administration was arbitrary and
capricious
in rejecting an illegal order from the
obama administration so in other words
it was okay for obama to put forward
illegal orders and we won't enforce the
law it is very bad for trump to put
forward
any legal order saying we will enforce
the law and we'll take back the old
illegal order
right that is that is basically the
rationale of the court justice thomas
just wrecks it today i mean justice
thomas
looks at this and he says you guys are
insane you basically made it
that your rationale is orange man bad
you don't like trump and so you're just
not going to enforce the law
he says dhs created daca during the
obama administration without any
statutory authorization without going
through the requisite rulemaking process
as a result the program was unlawful
from its inception the majority does not
even attempt to explain
why a court has the authority to
scrutinize an agency's policy reasons
for ascending an unlawful program
under the arbitrary and capricious
microscope the decision to counter man's
and unlawful agency action is clearly
reasonable
so long as the agency's determination of
illegality is sound our view should be
at an end
in other words if it is plausible for
the agency
in this case dhs to say that this is an
illegal order
then we don't get to review whether it's
any legal order because they've made the
determination
so if you're using the loose standard
did they get to decide that things are
randomly
legal like ignoring the law then you
can't suddenly tighten the standard and
say
okay and by the way if you go back to
enforcing the law then that's illegal
now
thomas says today's decision must be
recognized for what it is an effort to
avoid a politically controversial but
legally correct decision
the court could have made clear that the
solution respond and seek must come from
the legislative branch in other words
if you don't like immigration policy in
the united states then why don't you go
to the legislative branch i mean
congress exists
instead the supreme court has been
irrigating more and more power to itself
right over th
that's been the story of the last
several days of the supreme court
is the supreme court basically deciding
that congress isn't doing the equality
act so justice gorsuch will do the
equality act
right they'll just rewrite the civil
rights act in 1964 and read into its
sexual orientation and gender identity
neither of which are in
or were even remotely thought to be
within the scope of the civil rights act
of 1964.
we don't like the legislature not doing
what we wanted to do so we're just going
to rewrite the law it's what justice
roberts did when he rewrote obamacare to
make it
a tax instead of a fee right he
suggested oh you know what i
i don't really like what congress did
here so i'm just going to rewrite what
congress did here instead of just
striking it down and sending it back to
congress
and now the court is doing this with
daca they're saying we kind of like what
obama did
we kind of didn't like what trump did
instead of us just sending it back to
congress and saying take care of
business
we're just going to take care of it
ourselves so the supreme court keeps
irrigating power to itself now you may
be saying to yourself wait a second who
is the swing vote here
i was i was reliably informed that there
are five republican appointees to the
supreme court namely
justices roberts kavanaugh alito thomas
gorsuch right those were all republican
appointees that is a majority of the
supreme court guess who the swing vote
was again it was 5'4 swing vote justice
roberts of course of course
because justice roberts is constantly in
the mode of we want to basically
leave policy where it lay before right
that's justice roberts big thing is he
thinks that judicial activism
is overturning current action he doesn't
think of judicial activism
as completely rewriting the law for
political purposes roberts is just a
he's a disaster area on the court now
when i say disaster area
he still votes with his colleagues 80 of
the time but that extra 20
makes an awful lot of difference doesn't
it in obamacare in this particular case
so here's what we have on the court we
have five republican appointees
and we have a grand total of two
reliable
constitutionalist voices on the court
justices thomas and alito that's it
right we don't know where kavanaugh is
yet it's still early on kavanaugh so
we're waiting on kavanaugh
colored me a little bit skeptical that
kavanaugh is going to be anywhere in the
league of alito or thomas
okay and then you've got justice roberts
who's been a full-scale david suter
and then you have the and then you have
justice gorsuch
who's been very good except in this one
case which he was really really really
bad
right an overtly anti-textualist in
doing so and all the attempts to rewrite
justice gorsuch's opinion there to say
oh no he was being textualist he was
just being
talmudic about it no no if you have to
if you overtly say
no one could possibly have interpreted
this law as i am interpreting it now
when it was written
you're not a textualist okay you are
magically now rewriting the rules you're
rewriting the laws that's left in the
legislature
okay so bottom line is that this has
some pretty significant ramifications
for president trump
for for a couple of reasons one because
the big pitch for republican policy
policymakers and this has been true for
a long time
the big pitch has been listen we may not
do a lot when we're in congress in fact
we're pretty much going to do nothing
but the things that we are going to do
are tax cuts and judges right you're
going to get some tax cuts
which is great nice and we're going to
give you textualist
originalist judges who are going to
protect your rights well listen there
are a lot of
appeals courts where presumably that is
happening there are a lot more judges
than just the supreme court
but suffice it to say that three of the
last four judges
that republicans have appointed from the
presidency are questionable
three of the last four and if you go
back further than that then you have to
take into account
stevens you have to take into account
suitor you have to take into account
justice o'connor you have to take into
account justice kennedy in other words
republicans suck at this so if you think
that republican voting republican is a
guarantee that the supreme court
is going to be your bulwark for liberty
rongo grongo what you should be
demanding of your republican legislators
is actual conservative legislation
actually standing up and protecting your
rights at the legislative level
not just saying listen we're not going
to do much over here but you can rely on
the justices we pick because clearly
that ain't true
clearly that is not the case so one of
the chief kind of
mechanisms for gaining republican votes
turns out fairly flawed fairly flawed
republicans have a republican voters
have an absolute right
to point out that it's insufficient for
you to say you're going to appoint
conservative
judges because frankly we have no idea
whether that's true or not by the way
only one person i know me has opposed
two of the last four
republican judges appointed right
opposed to kavanaugh i posed roberts
so anyway we'll see where kavanaugh ends
up in coming up we're going to talk
about atlanta where things are going
south in a hurry
no pun intended we're going to get to
that in a second first let us talk about
the fact
that being at home reminds you of all
the important things you need to get
done and
how you need to protect your business
and how you want your business to run
when you get back to work and that means
you need to be all legally shored up
also you need to make sure that at home
you've got all your legal backup
prepared your will and your trust and
your estate and all that kind of stuff
this is why you need legalzoom you
didn't you don't need to hire a lawyer
at hundreds of dollars an hour instead
head on over to legalzoom i've been
using legalzoom myself for years long
before they were a sponsor
on this program legalzoom has been
dedicated to helping you with the right
solutions for more than 19 years
if you're looking to protect your family
with a will or a living trust or if
you're thinking about the right way to
start a business
with the dba llc nonprofit or more
legalzoom has you covered it's easy to
get started online
if you need guidance their network of
attorneys can provide advice to ensure
you make the right choices and since
legalzoom isn't a law firm you won't
have to leave your home
and you won't get charged by the hour
again getting charged by the hour that's
a great way to lose a lot of money to a
lawyer instead
head on over to legalzoom.com and get
all of your legal worries taken care of
visit legalzoom.com today
take care of some of the important
things you need to get done that's
legalzoom.com
legalzoom where life meets legal go
check them out right now and save
yourself a bundle
and get they have good legal advice
there too so go check them out right now
legalzoom.com okay so the supreme court
another pillar of american life that is
consistently being undermined by
people who staff it so that's that's
exciting stuff meanwhile
things are coming to a head with regard
to the situation in the united states
regarding police
so the lie has been pervaded the police
officers are broadly racist and brutal
it is a lie it is an overt lie the
evidence of this is
scanty at best the fact that lots of
people around the united states have
cameras
and that you can identify a few dozen
cases of police brutality
in a country where there are 375 million
interactions between the police and
civilians
on a yearly basis is not statistical
evidence and yet we have pressed forward
with the idea that the police are the
problem in the united states
that the police are the problem so we've
seen a historic crime decline in the
united states from 1994
all the way till now right with a couple
of bumps particularly the ferguson
time right ferguson 2014 2015 baltimore
2014 2015
but we've seen historic crime decreases
why because the police were staffed up
from 1994 and on
there were more police they were better
funded there were more of them in high
crime areas they were using smarter
policing tactics
and so we've decided that it's time to
do away with all that because obviously
the big problem
particularly facing black americans is
not high levels of crime
in black communities it is not poor
schools
in black communities it is not single
motherhood in black communities it's not
any of these things
the real issue that creates income
inequality and wealth inequality in the
united states is systemic american
racism beginning with the bleeding edge
the cops and so the best thing that can
happen is for the cops to go away
presumably
and this is where the defund the police
movement comes comes from if the police
are the problem remove the problem
and then you don't have to worry about
it anymore well we're about to find out
how this is going to work because we
have now decided to make it impossible
for police officers to do their job in
this country
that's what we have decided so a few
days ago you'll recall that there was a
big controversy
it was over the weekend i believe friday
there was a shooting in atlanta
the shooting involved a a suspect named
ray shard brooks
richard brooks had a very long criminal
record okay this is relevant because
when you drive up on somebody with a
very long criminal record you're
obviously going to treat it with caution
richard brooks had a long rap sheet
including obstructing police battery
possession of firearm and commission of
crime
drug dealing and multiple faps thefts
okay so they drive up on rayshard brooks
because somebody at the local wendy's
called
and said there's a guy who's asleep in
our drive-through he's obstructing
traffic
and he's behind the wheel of a car he's
out on parole by the way so violation of
parole means he goes back to jail
the police officers arrive for 25
minutes they have a nice
discussion with rayshard brooks they ask
him to walk a line he can't do it
they ask him to take a breathalyzer i
believe he refuses they
he he the the the conversation is
cordial
and extraordinarily long like for four
for 20 minutes more 25 minutes
they talk with this guy then they go to
cuff him because they say you know what
no we're not sending you home in an uber
you're drunk driving drunk driving by
the way is a very dangerous crime
i'm unaware of why it is that we're are
we supposed to let drunk drivers off now
like if you're driving drunk are we just
supposed to send you home and uber is
that the way this works anymore
i mean imagine that you send him home an
uber the next night he kills someone in
a drunk driving accident guess who gets
blamed the cops right no matter no
matter what how this thing turns out the
cops get blamed
so they they're talking with him it goes
on for a long time
they're obviously not attempting to get
into a confrontation they call for
backup
right and this goes on and on and on and
on then they go to arrest him and he
realizes oh wait
i'm on parole if they arrest me i'm
going back to jail and he starts to
resist arrest
and he resists arrest by taking down
both of the cops or surrounding him
he brings them both to the ground he
then proceeds he starts resisting he's
got his arms on his back then he breaks
loose
and you can see it in the video right
i'm showing you the video right now
he breaks loose he steals a taser off of
one of the police officers
right they tried to tase him in the leg
one of them tries to tase him in the leg
it doesn't work
right then he grabs the taser he
wrestles away from both officers
and he somehow gets loose at both
officers and he starts to run
okay so you're gonna see him again toss
these uh these big man rachael brooks
appears
okay and that only matters because again
there's a physical confrontation
he he breaks loose and he takes off the
police
start to chase him okay and then you can
see in the tape
he literally turns around he fires the
taser at the cop
and immediately the cop shoots him that
is that's the entire confrontation
that's the entire conference that is a
good shoot i've talked to a bevy of
police officers every single one of them
told
told me it is within police procedures
that if someone takes your taser off of
you and tries to tase you
you can shoot them because that is a
threat of deadly force how do you know
that that's a threat of deadly force
because if someone shoots you with a
taser first of all a taser could
theoretically be a deadly weapon
as it turns out you hit somebody the
right way with the taser they die but
beyond that
if a person has shown the willingness to
take a weapon off your body and they
shoot you with a taser and you have a
gun on your body
there is the significant possibility you
don't have to lie they're prone waiting
to see if the criminal is going to be a
nice guy and continue walking down the
street that's not how any of this works
according to atlanta police department
official procedure
you're allowed to defend your life if
there is the danger of significant
bodily harm to yourself or somebody else
okay so that's the case right that's the
whole case now there's some
additional question as to what happened
after they shot him
as we will see but that's the tape right
that's the important tape if you're
going to charge someone
that's the tape upon which you charge
somebody well
it turns out that they have decided to
charge that officer and they might put
him
on death row for that they might put him
on death row
i'm gonna get to the actual details of
this because it's perfectly insane it's
perfectly insane
and again it demonstrates why why social
and quote-unquote racial justice are not
justice
right justice is you get what you
deserve racial justice is you're a white
police officer you did something
justifiable but you did it to a black
guy in the middle of a massive national
controversy over policing and race
and therefore we are going to try you
for murder for felony murder
for defending yourself from a guy who
stole your taser and shot it at you
in the middle of an arrest after he was
arrested for a dui
really this is great for the great stuff
for the country really healing all
racial wounds and fixing our policing
problem
all at once incredible work everyone
we're gonna get to all the details of
this because it's absurd
it's a bullcrap charge everybody knows
it's a bullcrap charge including the da
who's pursuing it
everybody knows this and there's a
reason the da's pursuing this
and has nothing to do nothing to do with
what actually occurred on this tape
it has everything to do with the d.a
being in the middle of a hard-fought
re-election battle and being under
investigation by the georgia bureau of
investigation
this is corruption too we can get to
more of this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that it can
be daunting
to search out coupons for online
shopping but search no more
i've been telling you about honey you
probably know that honey is paypal's new
money-saving shopping tool did you know
that it does more than just
automatically apply coupons to your cart
it's a way to
save and get free gift cards to some of
your favorite stores so here's how it
works you shop just like normal
honey just runs in the background of
your computer then whether a promo code
is found or not
you can earn honey gold which is honey's
rewards points you let the gold points
pile up
and then you can cash out for free gift
cards to stores like amazon sephora
target and more
and it's honey's way of passing even
more savings onto you
from the commission it makes when you
check out right now our listeners can
head over
to joinhoney.com get 500 bonus gold
points but only if you use our special
url
just add honey to your browser and sign
up for an account that is it
if you're not using honey you're just
losing money and i've been using honey
for years at this point it's probably
saved me hundreds if not thousands of
dollars based on the discounts that it's
gotten for me and now
they have all these great programs where
you can get gift cards based on getting
that honey gold
not using honey it's giving away cash
add honey to your computer or laptop for
free
at joinhoney.com get 500 gold points
that's joinhoney.com
again joinhoney.com ben okay so
that police officer right in that case
has now been charged with felony murder
as well as 11 other charges his name is
garrett ralph he's 27
he is charged with murder in brooks's
death he could face life in prison or
the death penalty
for shooting a man who broke away from
police custody resisted arrest stole a
taser and tried to taser him
and now the d.a is just he's either a
liar an idiot i'm going to go with a
liar
and and he's following in the footsteps
of the mayor right the mayor
is just awful obviously the mayor of
atlanta
she suggested right away uh her last
name is bottoms is it
i'm trying to remember her first name
she she said right after this that the
shooting was unjust
based on nothing because we've all seen
the tape doesn't matter
she said it was unjust right away while
there may be
debate as to whether this was an
appropriate use of deadly force
i firmly believe that there is a clear
distinction
between what you can do and what you
should do
i do not believe that this was a
justified use of deadly force
and have called for the immediate
termination
of the officer so she fired the officer
right away
and then she declared that it was a
murder essentially and then
the d.a picked up on that and the reason
that the d.a picked up on that is again
because the da is in the middle of a
hard-fought re-election battle he also
happens to be under investigation
for a for a corruption case so
this is so political it's insane i mean
back in may the gbi the georgia bureau
of investigation opened an investigation
into the fulton county district attorney
the guy's name
is paul howard he apparently allegedly
used a non-profit to funnel at least 140
thousand dollars in city of atlanta
funds to supplement his salary
according to the atlanta journal
constitution he's being challenged
in the democratic primary for reelection
he's also facing allegations of sexual
sexual harassment which he strongly
denies so he's in the middle of a bad
re-election battle
he's under investigation by the gbi and
so he's decided you know what time to
make a headline for myself in a
different
way and pander to black voters
by unjustly charging a man i mean that's
that's obviously what is going on right
here he's attempting to pander to
democratic primary-based voters
particularly black voters
by suggesting that racial justice is
being done on behalf of a man who stole
a police officer's taser and tried to
tase the police officer and then was
shot for his trouble
so here are the charges that he's being
charged with and we need to actually
point this out
because the charges conflict i mean it's
the whole thing is
when you hear the da you'll see how
insane this is okay so rolf is facing
a bunch of charges felony murder he's
also facing aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon
the offense carries a possible sentence
of one to 20 years that is because
he uh he shot at him aggravated assault
for kicking brook so this was the only
real bombshell that was released by the
d.a
is that apparently there's third party
footage of rolf kicking the suspect when
he's down now the problem is he didn't
actually show the footage
all he showed was a still from the
footage so it would be nice to see the
actual footage
but if if brooks if brooks was kicked by
rolf after he'd been shot
that would be a case for assault it
would not be a case for felony murder
and if you kick somebody doesn't mean he
killed them right that is insult charge
that is not a felony murder charge
but this is my favorite part of the of
the indictment so the da
first of all normally the way this goes
is that the d.a works with the georgia
bureau of investigation the georgia
bureau of investigation does the
investigation and then they work with
the da to bring charges
this d.a rushed out the charges without
consulting with the gbi
perhaps because the gbi is investigating
him right now
okay and then he just rushed forward and
did what no prosecutor is supposed to do
he presented all of
the evidence in a very selective fashion
before this thing has even gone to a
grand jury by the way the actual result
of this is that it will go to a grand
jury and it probably will not go forward
to prosecution so he's making a headline
right now
and the prosecution probably will not go
forward because i cannot imagine a grand
jury going along with the idea that you
can prove beyond a reasonable doubt that
this officer was involved
in a in a felony murder that's insane
okay but here's my favorite part
he gets aggravated assault an aggravated
assault charge for kicking brooks
according to the an arrest warrant rolf
was wearing a shoe quote which
when used offensively against a person
is likely to or actually does result
in serious bodily injury now the reason
i particularly like this charge
is because as you will see this da is
claiming that if you fire a teaser at
somebody
that you are not in threat of serious
bodily injury if you kick somebody
yes the shoe is a weapon that could be
used for serious bodily injury but a
taser
is not a weapon that could be used for
serious bodily injury
also four counts of violation of oath by
a public officer a felony offense under
georgia law each offense carrying a
sentence of one to five years
prosecutors say that ralph broke his
oath and didn't follow police department
policies when he used a taser as brooks
ran away
failure to render timely medical aid to
brooks because after he was shot it took
a couple of minutes
for them to render medical aid and
failed to tell him he was under arrest
for driving under the influence
you know about the time when you are
being arrested for driving under the
influence after a 25 minute questioning
for driving under the influence i
figured that people might know
that they are being put under arrest for
driving under the influence which might
be why you resist arrest and run away
i don't understand is the implication
here that brooks thought that this guy
was going to take him home for dinner
like he didn't realize what he was being
arrested for what absolute absurdity by
the way the other
officer is now being charged as well
what did the other officer do
he's facing an aggravated assault charge
for standing on or stepping on brook's
shoulder while he was lying on the
ground
which by the way we haven't seen the
footage of that perhaps the reason is
because the guy's run before and you
don't know if he's actually dying right
so we don't know any of that he's also
charged with two violations of oath of
office which is basically just attack on
charge we're gonna get to
more of this in just a second because
this sort of bullcrap we'll get to the
da's statements it's insane this sort of
bullcrap charge
has a real consequence for policing and
the da also happens to be lying about
some of the facts here so we'll get to
that in
a moment first let us talk about a great
gift that you can get
for father's day for your family or for
yourself it really is great
that is a hand-painted portrait you
don't have to be one of those
richie riches like a tony soprano type
or get yourself painted with a horse or
something you have to stand there for
the still life or something
no it's not like that here's how it
works you actually send a picture into
paint your life you can pick
which painter is going to do the best
painting of you
and then they will turn your favorite
picture into a beautiful portrait
in a variety of sizes you can hang it
over your mantle i have one of me and
two of my three kids i'll actually have
to get another one so all three of my
kids
can be in it from paint your life it is
just fantastic i really enjoy it you'll
enjoy it too at paint yourlife.com there
is also no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed
right now as a limited time offer you
get 20 off on your painting that is
right 20
off and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word ben to sixty four
thousand that's ben
to sixty four thousand again text ben to
six four zero zero zero text ben to
sixty four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most this is a meaningful
gift and it's an awesome gift
it's a piece of art that your family is
going to cherish forever it's fantastic
go check them out right now
paintyourlife.com or text the word ben's
64 000 and get 20
off your gift order right now pretty
pretty awesome stuff okay so
the so this particular
this particular indictment that the
charges are just absurd they're
absurd on on virtually every level and
the da
his presentation of the facts are just
crazy so the da says at the time that
ray shaw brooks was shot he didn't pose
an immediate threat of death or injury
to the officer in fact he had the d
actually said
that he was very calm and collected in
his interaction with the police
that's true up until the point he tries
to break away from the police takes two
of them to the ground takes a taser off
the body of one of them
and then tries to shoot the other you
know up until then it was going fine
right how's it going they asked the man
who had just jumped from the seventh
story
on the fourth story he said everything's
going fine so far the interaction was
good
until it was not good right like this is
insane here is the fulton county d.a who
should summarily be dismissed from his
job for this prosecution
it's an absurdity it's an absurdity from
the outset from the get-go it's all on
tape
this is crazy here's the fulton county
dh just saying an idiotic thing
based on the way that these officers
conducted themselves
while mr brooks was lying there that the
demeanor of the officers
immediately after the shooting did not
reflect
any fear or danger of mr brooks
we've concluded at the time mr brooks
was shot
that he did not pose an immediate threat
of death
or serious physical injury to the
officer or officers oh did you did you
conclude that now
no serious threat of death or injury to
to the officers so
again to get this straight someone fires
a taser at you that's not a threat of
death or immediate injury to the officer
but a shoe is according to the actual
charges filed against the officer
plus um i will note that two weeks ago
the same d.a
prosecuted officers on the basis of
using a taser and called the taser a
deadly weapon
my i think my favorite part of this
particular clip is that there's a
picture of the man who's speaking right
behind the man who's speaking which is
one of my favorite things i always love
that sort of stuff
that little detail where there's a
picture of you behind you as you speak
is pretty spectacular it's like a jim
acosta
infinite regress of arrogance here is
the ca
with aggravated assault of ms pilgrim
and this is for pointing a taser at mrs
pilgrim and as many of you all know on
the georgia law
a taser is considered as a deadly weapon
under georgia law oh is it
is it now oh well that's weird
case dismissed i feel like right
seriously i mean like the
the defense attorneys all they have to
do is play the tape of the d.a saying
this and the case is dismissed
then he's not just gonna lie about that
he also says one officer has become a
cooperative witness
okay so he says this yesterday he says
the second officer is now cooperating
with us and is a cooperative state's
witness
there's only one problem with this the
attorney says no not true
she says we're not no that's not that's
not the case we're not going to
cooperate with the ca because he's
railroading people
because officer brosnan
is now becoming a cooperating
witness for the state we
are asking the court to
grant a bond of 50 000
and to allow mr officer brosnan to sign
that bond
as i indicated that he would become
one of the first police officers to
actually
indicate that he is willing to testify
against someone in his own department
this is a lie it is not true the
attorney for the other officer
whose name is devin brosnan they said
he's cooperating with the full team
county da's investigation and met with
the ada yesterday
but he has not agreed to be a state's
witness or to testify in any court
hearing or to plead guilty to any charge
the decision to initiate charges by the
fulton county da's office is irrational
obviously based on factors which should
have nothing to do with the proper
administration of justice
this was not a rush to judgment it was a
rush to misjudgment
according to the lawyer he also said
that brooks used the taser he took from
brazen against the officer as he
resisted arrest and later ran from the
scene
the lawyer says that brosnan sustained
burns from the taser
samuel also states that when brooks
began to violently resist arrest
brosnan's head hit the asphalt parking
lot and he was later diagnosed with a
concussion but don't worry
he was not a danger to anyone brooks
okay so this is perfectly insane
i mean perfectly perfectly insane but
apparently
all this is okay now again the only
piece of new evidence that we actually
got from the d.a yesterday was this
still photo of ralph kicking brooks we
haven't seen the actual video so we
don't know what was happening at the
time
other than the still photo so this was
the only piece of new evidence which
would suggest
that even if that was the case that he
ran up to the guy and kicked him
apparently the other piece of evidence
he said is that he said to his partner i
got him which by the way
is not evidence that you tried to murder
somebody if you're trying to collar a
suspect and the guy fires a taser and
you shoot him he says i got him
that doesn't mean i wanted to murder the
black guy i just had a 30 minute
conversation with in the parking lot of
wendy's
that is not what that means that is not
evidence of intent to murder you idiot
okay so the full encounter put out the
kick okay the kick is an assault
so you charge them with assault that's
called an assault
okay but you don't charge somebody with
felony murder for kicking somebody that
is not that's not how this works that's
not how this works at all
when we examine the videotape
and in our discussions with witnesses
what we discovered is during the two
minutes and 12 seconds
that officer roth actually
kicked mr brooks while he laid on the
ground
while he was there fighting for his life
okay and then we don't actually release
the tape we just released a still
forgive me if i don't trust this d.a
who seems to be completely full of crap
politically motivated and under
investigation by the gbi
forgive me if i have problems believing
that this guy is really acting the
interest of justice
rather than the interest of his own
career and in the interest of so-called
racial justice which suggests
that in in in order to rectify the
imbalances of criminal justice in
american history
this means that we have to straighten
out the stats even if that means that
people who ought not go to jail go to
jail and people who ought to go to jail
ought not go to jail
it's very very i mean incredibly
dangerous stuff that we're engaged in
and
with real ramifications as we're about
to talk about in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that it is
never a bad idea to save money and now
would be one of the greatest times in
the history of the world to save money
but there's certain stuff that you have
to do like home insurance right that's
something they actually have to have
so why would you waste money on
expensive home insurance you don't
actually need instead
get the best policy you can for the best
price you can at policygenius.com
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property and then
policy genius will compare your policy
against options from top insurers
and make sure you're getting the right
home insurance coverage at the best
possible price
if policy genius finds you a better rate
than what you're currently paying they
will do all the work to get you switched
if you own a car policy genius will
compare your home and auto policies
across different insurers even mix and
match and find you savings as well
they've saved their customers an average
of 1
127 bucks per year doing just that so if
you'd like to put a little cash back in
your pocket right now
see how much you can save by reshopping
your home insurance rates at
policygenius.com again that's
policygenius.com go check them out right
now
at policygenius.com they will help you
get the insurance
you need at the price you want and
they'll help you do it for all your
insurance disability insurance life
insurance home insurance auto
all the insurance you could possibly
need and they'll handle all the red tape
for you
at policygenius.com go check them out
right now okay we're going to get
into what happened in atlanta as a
result of this namely the cops were like
okay so here's the deal if i do my job
then you're going to prosecute me so how
about this how about i just don't i
just don't that's what happened last
night in atlanta we're going to talk
about that and why it's about to happen
across the country
in all likelihood plus we'll get to john
bolton tearing into the president in a
new book
get into that in one second first if
you're not already a daily wire member
you should consider getting a reader's
pass to dailywire.com why because the
media is bullcrapping you
all the time they're just lying to you
they are activists on the left for the
most part
you may as well get good conservative
journalism over at dailywire.com
you also get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials like my latest about how the
attempt to
create totalitarian cram-downs uh is is
really wrecking america
if you haven't checked out the reader's
pass already head on over to
dailywear.com and sign up
for just a buck also if you get the full
membership then you can ask us questions
on shows like our backstage tonight we
have a backstage live ooh
all your favorite hosts plus michael
knowles go check out backstage
live tonight that is me and jeremy
boring and andrew clavin
and the aforementioned expert michael
moles tonight 3 30 p.m pacific 6 30 p.m
eastern
also you should go check out my new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps it comes out july 21st i'm pushing
it early because i don't want you to
miss out on getting a copy the first day
that it comes out
it is so wildly relevant i cannot even
tell you it is
it is about how the country is
dissolving by getting rid of its common
philosophy
shared history and common culture of
rights how we're getting rid of all of
those things in the name of woke
intersectionality
and a variety of other dumbass
philosophies and it
and it rebuts the claims of the of the
intersectional
left and people who wish to disintegrate
the countries along class and race lines
it is more information than you could
possibly use
and it is better arguments for you to
make against people who wish to destroy
the country because that's really what
is happening
right now go check it out right now how
to destroy america in three easy steps i
don't think i've ever written a more
important book and i feel like i've
written a lot of important books this
one is
i think maybe the most important book
i've ever written go check it out how to
destroy america
in three easy steps it's out july 21st
you can pre-order today
at dailywire.com ben again that's
slash dailywire.com you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so last night in reaction to the the
atlanta d.a
going after an officer for a fully
justified shooting put aside what
happened after with the kicking maybe
there's an assault case there
don't know if you haven't seen the tape
we don't know if somebody's still
resisting right
we just don't know okay maybe again we
don't know does not mean
the officer is innocent of the thing it
means we don't know right just to
explain that sentence for people who are
morons
that's what that means what we do know
is that that was a justified shooting
because we have the tape of the shooting
so guys being prosecuted his partner is
being prosecuted
apparently everybody in a seven mile
radius except for criminals is being
prosecuted so that's exciting stuff
and so yesterday last night the atlanta
pd in many precincts across the city
they just called in sick
they said you know what not gonna do it
oops we all have coveted
whoops it was going around twitter it
was called the blue flu
by people including uh mike cernovich
and that that phrase has been around for
a while the rumors of a blue flu
uh that the police officers were
basically going to
start calling in sick and saying listen
we're not going to police crime
you want us to police crime well guess
what i'm happy to police crime so long
as you're not going to prosecute me for
police and crime but i'm not going to go
out there and
get killed for the sake of your
politically correct bull crap that's not
a thing i'm going to do
i've talked to a bevy police officer i
haven't talked to a police officer in
the last month
who's not suggested that they are
seriously considering early retirement
or leaving their major city department
because these departments are not
protecting their cops they are not
the vast vast majority of police
officers are heroes who stand between
you and villainy
every day and when you cast them as the
villains you should not be surprised
when they walk away and you are face to
face with real villains and that is what
is going to happen
in cities like atlanta i i you know this
is a data-based argument
i mentioned a study the other day from
roland fryer
another researcher from i believe the
national economic council
that showed that in the aftermath of
viral incidents in places like ferguson
and baltimore and cincinnati and
riverside
that in the aftermath of viral incidents
that prompted major investigations of
police departments
policing basically stopped in those
cities leading to 900
excess deaths 900 excess homicides in
the aftermath now think about that in
every major city in the united states
which is basically what is happening now
it's happening in l.a it's happening in
seattle it's happening in new york it's
happening in atlanta it's going to
happen in chicago
what do you think happened even the cops
who stay on the job do you think that
they're just going to
proactively police now they'll respond
to 9-1-1 calls but only after somebody's
been shot and is bleeding out presumably
so a bunch of precincts of atlanta
walked out last night
one observer who was sort of observing
the radio traffic said
that this afternoon when the da
announced murder charges were filed
almost an entire shift in a patrol zone
drove back to the precinct said they
needed to talk to the eap or weren't
feeling well
another specialty squad did the same the
overnight shift had multiple sick outs
the officers are broken abandoned after
eight officers were fired and charged by
this da two weeks ago the officers were
outraged
more to that story didn't get told they
didn't handle it correctly but the
aggravated assault criminal charges
didn't sit well
during the middle of riots when the da
charged these officers three outside
agencies pulled their officers back home
i can't have my officers placed in a
situation like this the mayor has
already taken away the raises they were
promised
and given control of the budget to the
clo the apg has already basically been
defunded nine of the 15 council members
voted to take back the money their chief
was fired
basically for being a white lady it's
now a black head of the apd by the way
you know it's worth noting the atlanta
pd 58 black as of 2016.
58 black the da is charging officers
before the gbi even does an
investigation
most of them are in their 20s they
aren't going to work to kill a black man
or anyone for that matter the department
is about 65
black as of now apparently not just 58
black as it was back in 2016.
and and the mayor is trying to hold this
thing together despite going cracking
down on the cops
don't worry guys it's fine it's fine she
was on cnn last night as atlanta police
officers were calling in sick across
the county they do it for one night and
it'll probably be okay but they had to
lie right they came out
no we're just having a higher than
average call out
it's not people aren't calling in sick
it's not it's not a blue flu we just had
it sort of a higher than average people
calling in sick today
try this for like two weeks and see how
it goes not one night once the criminals
know that the cops are not on the
streets and not responding to calls
then see how it goes by the way she was
apparently trying according to a lot of
the radio traffic
the the atlanta police department the
the dispatchers were trying to call in
people from
surrounding counties and the surrounding
country was like nope you're on your own
i'm not going down there i'm not getting
prosecuted for you guys nope not going
to happen
so kesha bottoms the mayor said it's
okay we have enough officers kind of
whistling past the graveyard here
we don't have a account yet because we
were in the midst of a shift change but
what i do know
is that we do have enough officers to
cover us through
the night and um our streets won't be
any less safe because of the number of
officers who've called out
but it's it's just my hope again that
our officers will remember the
commitment
that they made when when they held up
their hand
and they were sworn in as police
officers
according to charlie gile of nbc news
producer over there he says atlanta
police union spokesman vince champion
tells me officers around the city are
protesting the charges announced against
officers ralph and brosnan
this is they're walking off the job not
responding to calls unless backup is
needed and going silence on the radios
and if you listen to the radio traffic
last night that was perfectly obvious
that was happening you can do that for
one night you can't do it for two weeks
you can't do it for a week get ready for
the purge in atlanta right i mean
that's that's what this is gonna be i
love that the mayor is like oh yeah
morale is just down at the police
department i can't really explain why
morale is down except that i just called
my officers murderers who didn't commit
a murder but aside from that
can't really explain why the morale is
down
across the country morale is down with
police departments and i think ours is
down
tenfold this has been a very tough few
weeks
in atlanta and with the tragedy of
mr brooks and then on top of that the
excessive
force of charges that were brought
against the officers involved with the
college students
there's a lot happening in our city and
our police officers
are receiving the brunt of it quite
frankly
okay so good times right there so
atlanta is just the beginning
we've already heard evidence that there
are going to be blue outs in places like
los angeles where people were not being
paid proper over time that the lapd
was just going to be like you know what
we're not we're not doing this anymore
we're not going to police the metro
that's been a major issue in los angeles
you've already seen rumors that over 600
police officers in
new york are looking at possibly leaving
the police force if this is going to
happen at places across the country
because what we were watching the
assault on police from
public figures across the aisle it's not
going to end well
folks because guess who stands between
the criminals and innocent citizens
particularly black and and brown
citizens by the way it's uh it
it's going to those are the police you
remove the police the crime is going to
go up that is not going to hurt the
people who are living in beverly hills
it's not going to hurt all of the white
woke liberal hipsters on college
campuses where hashtagging black lives
matter it's going to hurt all the people
who are going to be killed in areas with
high crime disproportionately in black
and brown communities
that's the reality here and it's an ugly
reality
the posturing from all of the white wilk
liberals
meets the reality that when you remove
the cops from high crime scenarios crime
goes up
always not sometimes always and don't
give me camden new jersey where they got
rid of the police department by doubling
the size of the police department and
getting rid of the local police union
which is what actually happened there
meanwhile the you know bottom says there
keisha bottoms the the mayor of atlanta
she says that the morale is down in the
police department morale is down across
the country and their polls showing
right now that americans are less
satisfied with the united states than
they have been in 50 years
that is not a giant surprise maybe one
of the reasons for that is because
everyone sort of feels like they are
being treated
unfairly you have an entire narrative on
one side of the aisle that declares that
america is sexist
racist bigoted homophobic horrific in
every way so if you remember a minority
group you're being told over and over
every day that your fellow american is
seeking to keep you down
and something michelle obama actually
said to people no matter how hard you
work as a young black person
the system is designed to keep you down
right that's pretty depressing
and then if you are not a member of a
minority group you are told that you are
suffering from white privilege
or that you're the beneficiary rather of
white privilege and that
any any move you make to be colorblind
is actually
just an emanation of your own white
privilege and we are going to call
you out we're going to go after you
we're going to uncover every bad thing
you have ever done
it's it's the salem witch trials we're
going to go after you and if you sink to
the bottom
then we know you're innocent but if you
float then we know you're a witch and we
burn you
really really exciting stuff over at the
washington post they're going through
whole scale
full-scale purges i i do i do love this
story there's a story by mark fisher and
sydney trent
the picture on the story has a picture
of two
washington post staffers one named lexi
gruber and one named lyric prince
standing next to a statue in the park
looking very very determined
very determined people what is it what
are they so determined about what sort
of
grand conspiracy have they uncovered
what sort of woodward and bernstein
journalism
have they done to merit such a wonderful
photo quote
blackface incident at post cartoonist
2018 halloween party resurfaces
amid protests the washington post
is now calling out bad old halloween
costumes this is a
3 000 word piece in the washington post
3 000 words on how a person wore a
non-woke costume
to a washington post halloween party in
2018.
now the great irony of the woke costume
is that the woke costume was supposed to
be woke
the unworld costume was supposed to be
woke here is the here is the
harrowing story of racism
over at the washington post are you
ready for this and the staffer's already
been fired
quote every year tom told's halloween
party draws an eclectic mix
journalists and political types from
washington's power elite but also
artisan musicians
everyone from retirees to college kids
jammed into small rooms and sprawled
across the backyard
dancing and gossiping checking out the
crowd to see who has the most inventive
and outrageous costumes at the 2018
party at the home of the washington post
editorial cartoonist in addition to
several ruth bader ginsburgs someone
dressed as the mueller witch hunt and
post columnist dana milbank
came as just confirmed just supreme
court justice brett kavanaugh complete
with a beer dispensing device on his
head
a guest named lexi gruber where a scary
beetlejuice get up and calls herself
dead
wow a middle-aged white
white named sue schaefer wore a
conservative business suit and a name
tag that said
hello my name is megan kelly her face
was almost entirely blackened with
makeup
kelly then an nbc morning host had just
said that week
she'd caused a stir by defending the use
of blackface by white people saying when
i was a kid that was okay as long as you
were dressing up as like a character
okay first of all if you recall that was
a bullcrap story in the first place
because what megan was not doing
was defending actual blackface she was
saying there's a difference as by the
way juan williams has said on my show
right juan williams the black
commentator for fox news there's
obviously a difference between you
dressed up as michael jackson in 1985
and you dressed up like ralph northam
did just plainly in blackface in 1985
like that is not the same thing but in
any case put aside the kelly controversy
this lady this middle-aged white woman
was making fun of megyn kelly for
supposedly being racist
by dressing up as megan kelly in
blackface it was not because she was
doing blackface
right that like she's so woke that she's
on woke she was dressed up as megan
kelly
and she had black on her face because
she's my she's supposed to be making fun
of that evil conservative vicious racist
megan kelly and now she's being targeted
as a racist for targeting the supposed
racist megan kelly and now she has been
announced for her racism
just before heading over to the party
schaefer a graphic designer and friend
of tolls decided to dress as kelly in
blackface to mock her she said
well yes clearly because that's
perfectly obvious some of the
approximately 100 guests at the home of
the cartoonist
in the district's american university
neighborhood said they didn't notice the
blackface some noticed it and said
nothing
a few people walked over to shaper
schaefer who was then 54 and challenged
her about the costume
gruber who's of puerto rican descent and
her friend lyric prince who's
african-american confronted schaefer
directly
you understand how offensive that could
be to a person of color gruber said
according to two witnesses
i'm megan kelly it's funny schaefer
replied the witnesses said nearly two
years later the incident which has
bothered some people
ever since ever since but which many
guests remember only barely or not at
all has resurfaced ooh
resurfacing in the nationwide reckoning
over race by the way resurfaced is code
for awoke staffer decided to go up and
dick up an old photo to get somebody
fired that's what resurfaced means
it's not like we're bobbing out here on
the eddies of time and it's only oh look
a picture
propped up look it just it resurfaced
magically i was just here on the lake
of news and boom up came the picture
nope that's not how that works
resurfaced this code for awoke staffer
decided to get somebody fired
for an unfunny halloween costume that
was targeting supposed racism that
wasn't even racism in the first place
well done everyone the story goes on for
000 words gruber felt compelled to
revive the 2018
18 incident last week she emailed tolls
she said in 2018 i attended a halloween
party at your home
i understand you're not responsible for
the behavior of your guests but at a
party
a woman was in blackface she harassed me
and my friend the only two women of
color it was clear she made her costume
with racist intent
which obviously is not true according to
the washington post's own story the two
people approached her
and then started harassing her about
being a supposed racist
gruber a 27 year old management
consultant told tolls the incident had
quote weighed heavily on my heart
it was abhorrent and egregious and then
asked him to help her identify the woman
it didn't resurface
this lady kept this around in her in the
back of her mind so she could get a
heroic picture in the washington post
forgetting another washington post
employee and graphic design fired
for a costume that was not racist okay
again the costume is not racist because
it's making fun of the evils of
blackface you stupid idiots
it is not about how blackface is good
it's making fun of the evils of
blackface
you know after the killing of george
floyd in the protest i began reflecting
more on this incident gruber said in an
email seeking post coverage of the
incident
i wanted to know who the woman is what
impact does she have on society
i think this is an important story that
a party full of prominent people in
washington
welcomed a person in blackface danced
and drank with her and watched in
silence as she harassed
two young women of color prince 36 a
science writer art critic and artist
wants shafer to explain publicly
why she did what she did i don't want an
apology that time has long
passed she said she wants tolls to make
it clear that what shafer did was wrong
that's not the kind of person he knows
to be a good person she's a bad person
now
we now know everything we need to know
about about this person because she
dressed up as megan kelly
in blackface to mock megyn kelly
looking back some guests at the party
say they wish they had confronted shay
for more aggressively
others say she's already paid a price
and that her embarrassment aggress were
evident when she left the party
in tears i wish i'd been the one to call
her out said felipe hughes
a washington arts entrepreneur i mean
it's just malice crap i'm sorry
it's just unbelievable malice crap tolls
a 68 year old pulitzer prize winner
replied to gruber's email last week with
apologies for your experience at the
party
a lot of people show up i don't know i
don't recognize the woman you're
inquiring about
tolls didn't know schaefer ooh so now he
must be fired
he said i meant i didn't recognize any
bad intent and if it was my place to
tell her who my other guest was when she
had misinterpreted what the other guest
intended
with her costume i mean this is just
it's plainly insane this goes on
and on and on and on 3 000 words because
a 27 year old
is so weak-minded that she believes a
costume that is meant to mock the evils
of blackface is actually horrifically
racist to the point where two years
later she's still having bad dreams
about it has to get the person fired
well i i wonder why people are feeling
so negative about the future of the
united states i just can't imagine why
i can't imagine why when the woke
schools are not only out in force they
are forcing people to have their job
loss i mean this lady is what now 56
years old
you're firing a 56 year old lady because
she wore a liberal costume
making fun of megyn kelly to a
washington post party and then the
washington post does a three thousand
word me a couple with hero pictures of
the people who are offended
and can you just tell something about
being offended being offended does not
make you virtuous very often it makes
you a weakling
if you are that offended by these like
as a person
who's the number one target of all
anti-semitism on the internet in 2016
and watched people send me actual memes
of
my of me being gasped by hitler okay it
takes a lot to offend me
guess what i still need a happy life i
don't have a bunch of of nightmares
about that
okay as my wife i've mentioned this
before my wife as a
as a an israeli-american woman walking
with her father in sacramento
a man drove past threw a rock at her and
yelled killed the jews does she have
nightmares about that she's mentioned it
to me once in our 12 years of marriage
those are all worse things then i saw a
costume that made me feel bad at a party
even though the costume was supposed to
be making fun of alleged racism
these are your reporters these are your
journalists and someone put it online
gawker didn't go away it just became the
washington post
that's all that's happening now we're
now outing all the bad all the baddies
all the baddies have to be outed
making america a worse place one mobbing
at a time well
done everybody okay meanwhile
you want to talk about more ridiculous
sort of
of woke scolding so there are a couple
more stories that are worth noting in
the woke scolding lane and then we'll
get to john bolton for a little while
here because john bolton is of course a
big story cause john bolton wrote a book
a book okay and then just confirmed
everything we knew about president trump
he says rash and stupid things
who who knew that who except for every
observer of president trump
that he says rations stupid things and
says the quiet part out loud and is
completely unsubtle and tactless
and very often we'll say things that are
bad about america who knew that except
for everyone who's ever seen his twitter
account
every human that is okay we'll get to
that in a second first let's talk for a
second about
you know people seeking to be offended
at this point again offense has become a
virtue
if you take offense at a thing you are
now virtuous you get the hero pose over
the washington post
you get the full front page splash and
3000 words because you were offended by
a halloween party
in 2018. slow clap for you you're martin
luther king you're rosa parks
well done well done you're malcolm x
you've really stood up to true american
prejudice
by calling out a lady who you didn't
know from two years ago at a washington
post editorial cartoonist party
amazing amazing stuff well looking for
his
merit badge of offendedness is tim gray
a columnist for variety
10 problematic films that could use
warning labels uh we now need more
warning labels
we need trigger warnings remember that
time when um
i used to talk about trigger warnings
and microaggressions on the show and in
my college
speeches people like that's not going to
enter the real world these young people
they're going to get out there and then
the real world's going to the real
world's going to hit you hard bro
the real world is going to change them
they're going to come face to face with
reality
and then it turned out that reality came
face to face with the woke schools and
ran
and the new reality is the more offended
you are the more virtuous you are
so find your find something that offends
you and you too can be initiated into
the woke
into the woke priesthood where you can
rip out the
entrails of your enemies and spoil and
just
spread them on the ground and read the
auspices okay so there's a piece of
variety
it's not enough to go after gone with
the wind instead they have now a list of
10 problematic films that could use
warning labels
films should be viewed with a critical
eyes as this columnist that doesn't mean
banning them
these films represent the era in which
they were made it's important to
remember history so we don't repeat
those things but here are 10 films that
need to be presented with disclaimers
and discussions before and after
entering a screening
dirty harry from 1971. lieutenant harry
callahan of the san francisco police
department is determined to uphold the
law even if he has to break the rules
it started a craze for movies about
maverick cops who get the job done
by following their instincts rather than
the law the film mocks liberal judges
and do-gooders and the villain claims
police brutality
planting the seed that other such
charges are fake moves to get sympathy
and one of the things that they're not
going to mention is the dirty harry was
an extraordinarily popular movie because
it came amidst one of the great crime
waves in american history beginning
in the mid 60s and culminating in 1994.
dirty harry was a direct reactionary
response to the fact that criminality
was being allowed to run wild by the
left that's what dirty harry was it's
why it was popular
same thing with the movie death wish
both of those movies were very popular
because they were actually responding to
the ridiculousness
of the left taking over taking over the
auspices of
of law and order and destroying them
forest gump apparently is bad
forrest gump is very bad forrest gump
was made by intelligent people won six
oscars and is beloved by many while the
film is condescending to anyone with a
disability vietnam vets and people with
aids among others it's actually hostile
to protesters
activists in the counter culture as a
bonus lovable title character nathan
bedford forest was named after his
grandfather
the first grand wizard of the kkk so
forrest gump is canceled
indiana jones and the temple of doom uh
we have to get rid of indiana jones in
the temple of doom
because the exotic villains are
portrayed as primitive and bloodthirsty
foreigners
resulting in negative and stereotypical
depictions of india and of hindu customs
i'm pretty sure that anybody who watched
temple of doom didn't go away thinking
i feel like all hindus just like rip
hearts out of chests
it's an actual temple called like what
what are you
apparently me before you needs to be
done away with
me before you because it's really
insensitive because it's a romance about
a man who becomes paralyzed after an
accident and falls in love with his new
companion
and then he urges her to live her life
to the fullest instead of living half a
life with him so he kills himself
presenting the idea that suicide is
better than life with a disability
so first of all i agree with the take on
the film but i wonder why it needs a
disclaimer
once upon a time in hollywood is also
very bad very very bad
because the film is set in 1969 when
some americans felt the status quo was
being threatened by minorities hippies
and newly liberated women
from the controversial depiction of
bruce lee to the fact that black people
seem non-existent and the mexicans as
they're called in the film are car
valets or waitresses
tarantino's film seems to have several
blind spots
wow also the searchers is bad the search
is canceled silence of the lambs is
canceled
which is exciting true lies is cancelled
as well
by the way the reason that um that
silence of the lambs is canceled
is because the criminal is trans
so that's very so that's bad that's bad
you can't never have a trans criminal
all trans people are are good
just like all straight people oh no
sorry the only villains were allowed
are actually white straight people those
people are those people are villains
well done variety you are offended
congratulations congratulations virtue
has been conferred upon you
how bad has this stuff become the city
of seattle
has now put out i'm not kidding you this
is according to
dr carolyn borsenko is an organizational
psychologist
the city of seattle asked its white
employees to voluntarily spend a day off
in a training about their internalized
racial superiority there's an email
that was sent out to to white employees
it says
the office of civil rights is hosting a
training on internalized racial
superiority tomorrow morning
specifically targeted for white
employees
they say we're opening up this friday's
long scheduled citywide rsji
training on internalized racial
superiority and training for white
people to additional white city
employees we'll hold the training on
microsoft teams from 9 30 a.m to 12
30 to 12 o'clock p.m white employees not
already registered can sign up at the
link below
tomorrow many city employees will be
using paid or unpaid leave to take a day
of reflection in action this is during
blackout tuesday or what is that what
it's called i think that's what it was
called
um i can't i can't remember we're
inviting city employees who identify as
white
to join this training to learn reflect
challenge ourselves and build skills and
relationships that help us show
more fully as allies and accomplices for
racial justice we'll examine our
complicity
in the system of white supremacy this
was sent out by the city of seattle to
its white employees
nothing like a little racial targeting
of your white employees and suggesting
they ought to take
the day off that's been given to them to
consider their racial guilt
and come on in to learn about their
internalized white superiority
yes i wonder why so many people are
negative maybe it's because things suck
right now like radically suck right now
in a huge way
okay meanwhile i would be remiss if i
didn't talk at least a little bit about
john bolton's book so john bolton has a
496 page book out which
i mean frankly sounds interminable i
don't like reading
political books that are that long
because they rarely justify the word
count
i've also i'll admit i've gotten to the
point in my life where
i will get if there's an 800 page book
and i start it and i get 500 pages in
and i get bored i'll just i'll just put
it down i just don't have that many
breaths left in my life when i was when
i was younger
i would be like okay i'm gonna blow my
way all the way through the end of this
thing but
if i'm reading vanity fair and it's 900
pages long and i get to page 700
and i'm like okay this i feel like i got
the gist i get how the writing works all
right let's let's move on i'll just read
the rest of the plot and put it down
like that so i feel that way about
bolton's book which
i believe is in the mail for me so i
will let you know how it is after i read
the first 300 pages of his 496-page tone
so let me say right at the outset i
think that john bolton is an honest
person
okay i've met ambassador bolton several
times uh
i do not think he is a liar i think
people who are trying to flip on him now
that he is saying things that are
anti-trump
that's sort of absurd the idea that
bolton is just making things up full
scale
why is it that everybody who turns
against trump is a liar but trump
himself is considered the epitome of
honesty like
that's just not something i believe now
do i think that it is
worthwhile for john bolton to talk out
of school i generally don't think that
it's worthwhile for government officials
to talk out of school unless they quit
over a matter of principle and want to
talk about the matter of principle
but this idea that you're going to sit
in on meetings for three years and take
the benefits of the job and try to swing
the job
and then you're just going to go out and
talk about it that's really kiss and
tell kind of stuff that i'm really not
fond of i'll also say that most of the
things that we learn about
donald trump in in the excerpts of the
book that we've seen are not particular
revelations
namely he says horrible things truly
horrible things
that he is completely transactional in
his approach to politics
that he says the quiet part out loud the
real difference between donald trump and
barack obama
is that barack obama was the
sophisticated version of trump so i'll
give you a perfect example
so one of the big headlines from from
this is that apparently
he talked to trump talked to xi jinping
about his re-election right so according
to john bolton
president trump was constantly motivated
by reelection which by the way is true
for virtually every president
right barack obama always had knights
reelection so bolton says in a piece in
the wall street journal
i am hard-pressed to identify any
significant trump decision during my
white house tenure that wasn't driven by
re-election calculations
okay which is called welcome to politics
i mean john bolton knows this
so he he says that trump saw his
meetings with g
not as a policy issue to be resolved but
as an opportunity to make personal
personal gestures to xi
in 2018 for example he reversed
penalties that had been carried out by
the commerce department on zte
in 2019 he offered to reverse criminal
prosecution against huawei
if it would help in a trade deal which
of course was primarily about getting
trump
re-elected in 2020. right so so
apparently
he talked openly with xi about the fact
that he wanted g to start importing all
sorts of agricultural products because
if he imported agricultural product
then then trump would have the ability
to win some of the swing states
so is that good no it's not good of
course it's not good you don't want the
president of the united states going to
foreign dictators and being like you
know it'd be great
if you could help me out with my
re-election prospects by importing some
of our agricultural goods and just give
me a win here just give me a win here
that's really bad
i'm old enough to remember when barack
obama literally said to dimitri medvedev
tell vladimir i have more flexibility
after this election
right okay so trump obama did the same
thing he was just a lot more
sophisticated about how he did it and
tried to do it off mike
he failed in that instance but this idea
that politicians are never thinking
about reelection
and never talk with foreign leaders with
an eye toward reelection is very silly
right this is a distinction that i made
when we were talking about trump in
ukraine
i said if one of the motivations for a
president is re-election
if it is not the only motivation but if
one of the motivations is re-election
then that's just called politics because
that's what politicians do
okay so that's that one is sort of the
least of my concerns among the john
bolton bombshells some of the other john
bolton bombshells is just
trump generally going easy on china
because he was trying to win over xi
jinping on a personal level this is
again an aspect of trump's negotiation
that i've always thought is dumb
obviously the worst thing that
apparently
trump said is that he was talking with
xi jinping
about so the about xi jinping's
concentration camps
for uyghur muslims and apparently he
suggested
that he was okay with them right that's
the part that that's ugly
but he he was asked about it that like
there's no justification for that
according to bolton at the opening
dinner of the osaka g20 meeting in june
2019 with only interpreters president
present she had explained to trump why
he was basically building concentration
camps
in xinjiang according to our interpreter
trump said that she should go ahead with
building the camps which trump thought
was exactly the right thing to do
the national security council's top asia
staffer matthew pottinger told me that
trump said something very similar during
his november 2017.
trip to china apparently trump was
particularly dyspeptic about taiwan
having listened to wall street
financiers who'd gotten rich off
mainland china investments
apparently trump used to point to the
resolute desk and say this is china and
then point to the
tip of his sharpie and say this is
taiwan
he said none of this is good there's
stuff about concentration camps
apparently trump was asked about it and
trump said something like america does
bad things too
so the question isn't did trump say a
very bad thing and is that a horribly
evil thing to say that concentration
camps are
okay yes that is a horribly evil thing
to say with no justification whatsoever
also this is coming from the same guy
who said openly in an interview with
bill o'reilly in 2016.
that vladimir putin routinely killing
his political enemies america does bad
stuff too
don't you remember that he said that i'd
lose february 2016.
hey you want to criticize putin well
america kills people too
and i was one of the people going like
uh what now so this has been a constant
trump refrain in other words
things can be bad without being news and
i'm wondering what exactly is the news
here
i'm not saying anything newsy here john
bolton is is making the rounds though
and he says trump isn't fit for office
he did an interview with
abc news i believe uh in which he in
which he went after trump pretty hard
i don't think he's fit for office i
don't think he has the confidence to
carry out the job there really isn't
any guiding principle that i was able to
discern
other than what's good for donald
trump's reelection
i think he was so focused on the
re-election
that longer-term considerations
uh fell by the wayside so if he thought
he could get a photo opportunity with
kim jong-un at the demilitarized zone in
korea
there was considerable emphasis on the
photo opportunity and the press reaction
to it
and little or no focus on what such
meetings did for the bargaining position
of the united states
okay so again he disagrees with the
policy this makes him no different
bolton than any other officer who's left
the trump administration he sounds like
jim mattis
he sounds like he sounds like rex
tillerson he sounds like everybody who
has left the trump administration on bad
terms with trump
or who's basically been fired by trump
they all say they don't like trump they
all say that trump is incompetent they
all say trump doesn't know anything
they'll say they disagree with him on
policy and that he's driven by pure
election concerns and and sort of
trade tit-for-tat politics all of which
is
perfectly obvious from everyone right
everyone knows this so again not news
would be sort of where i put this
like saying things that are worse than i
thought he had said maybe that's news
the concentration in camp again
is inexcusable on every possible level
it's just terrible
but and the butt is not with regard to
the comment
it's not really super newsy considering
that now now does this mean that john
bolton's a liar
this this narrative i find completely
tiresome so president trump went out and
slammed and said
okay if if forced to the map between do
i believe
that trump did these things because john
bolton saw them or is trump lying
to further himself that is not a choice
okay i do not think that trump is honest
as the day is long and i think that
you'd have to be a sucker to believe
that he is
i here's president trump going after
bolton by the way his best move here
would be to just ignore it
that would be his best move politically
speaking just be like you know
disgruntled former staffer we're done
that's all he should do but will
president trump ever let a sleeping tug
light
no not at all go for it
he broke the law he was a washed up guy
i gave him a chance
uh he couldn't get senate confirmed so i
gave him a non-senate confirmed position
i could just put him there see how he
worked and
i wasn't very enamored he went into the
middle east he was one of the
the big guns for let's go into iraq and
that didn't work out
too well and i was against that a long
time ago before i was ever even thinking
about doing what i'm doing now
okay so yeah is this helpful not really
robert lighthizer another trade adviser
to trump he said
that bolton is completely crazy that all
this stuff is made up
here's my rule of politics and it's
through across the board my rule of
politics is always this
whatever is bad that people say about
each other is true
whatever is good that people say about
themselves is false always always
inevitably
okay now unless they are making some
sort of like
patently absurd accusation like brett
kavanaugh's guilty of gang rape if
somebody says i was in the room and this
person said x and it was a bad thing
they said and the person says no i never
said it
generally believe the bad things in
politics because everybody's
self-motivated everybody's
self-motivated and then you decide okay
is that news is that is that changeable
the the media's newfound respect for
john bolton is something to behold
although i will say the media are pretty
upset at john bolton because they're
like where were you during impeachment
dude
like where were you chris hayes went
after john bolton yesterday and frankly
i think he sort of has a point
he's a vicious bureaucratic infighter
he's duplicitous
untrustworthy extremely militaristic
he's never been held accountable for all
the terrible things he's done
in his long public career and there are
many he's a completely morally odious
individual
you would not want your organization or
anywhere around you and yet he is of
course also a fox news contributor
and at the highest levels of republican
policy making john bolton could spend
the rest of his life like lady macbeth
trying to wash the blood off his hands
and it would be there still
and now bolton is attempting to
literally cash in on betrayal of his
country
again all of which is par for the course
of the modern republican party
okay so again the only part of this i
actually agree with chris hayes not the
characterization of bolton but
the idea that bolton was like avoiding
testimony avoiding testimony avoiding
testimony than he says in his book you
know if the democrats had broadened out
their impeachment inquiry to include all
transactional politics for trump they
would have a better shot
yeah you know if you really thought that
you could have said that at the time
john bolton
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with all your covet updates
there is so much news it is impossible
to cram it all into one show
which is why we have another one
tomorrow and we have a backstage live
tonight so go head on over to
dailywire.com and subscribe
you're listening to the shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
atlanta police officers walk off the job
aunt jemima gets canceled and the boy
scouts get woke
check it out on the michael knowles show